how do I make money so I got a great
question for one of my newsletter
readers Antoinette she wrote in the say
Evan how did you get started with your
business was it with free newsletters
your a website and how do you make money
is it from the worksheets affiliates how
is it that you make money
she's starting up a coaching practice
and wanted my advice on how the time to
get start was the best way to get
started so let me tell you my story I
when I sold my software company I own my
domain name and I I was just using it as
a way to tell my story has invited to do
a lot of speaking Evan karma calm was
just a place to share where I was
speaking and I also loved modeling
famous entrepreneurs this is what saved
me my business this is what got me over
the hump from from struggling $300 a
month to actually make a successful
company modeling other successful
entrepreneurs and so I just started
sharing the stories on my site I wish I
could say I had this whole thing planned
out and said I knew from the start what
I was doing where I was going but I had
no idea there was no huge plan I was
just going going off of what I was
excited by what I was passionate about
and from there people started sharing
articles they asked me what they can
contribute to my site as well and I
hooked up with a venture capital company
and I used my website just as a way to
be a lead generation for the venture
capital site I later discovered that hey
this could be a source of advertising
and I built my website up to be a
article portal with my own articles with
other people contributing and I sold
advertising against that and for a
number of years that's that was my model
and I had a newsletter and all this
stuff and I was selling advertising I I
grew increasingly dissatisfied with the
advertising business one because you end
up creating content just to get a lot of
eyeballs not necessarily what's going to
help people I don't know you do that
long enough like I want to help people I
want to create stuff that helps people
if I make this video and it helps just
you I'm happy with that
and a lot of the websites that's the
game like you have to create content and
use the keywords and put up stuff that's
gonna generate tons of traffic because
that's how you sell advertising and I
just grew increasingly dissatisfied so I
I kind of slipped my business up where I
gave the content part of my business to
somebody on my team and the advertisers
and all that and I started focusing on
things that I love doing the speaking
the videos the helping entrepreneurs
one-on-one groups whatever just stuff
that I was passionate about and as a
group two businesses grew kind of grew
and started going on different paths and
recently maybe six months ago I thought
you know what like I I want to stand for
something good I want people have a
great experience with my website I don't
want to just be in the advertising game
I want to really help people and so I
merged my website to come back and meet
me and so now there's no advertising on
my website and it just shut off that
business model as we've gotten a lot
better traction a lot better results
we've helped a lot more people how I
make money now with my site I don't do
coaching people want me to coach them a
lot it's just it's not the business I
want to be in so I don't do coaching I
make money from sponsorships so I work
with companies and help create content
for them so only companies where I'm
adding value so I don't want to work
with the company and say hey go buy this
phone because the greatest thing ever
right because that you know kills my
credibility and it doesn't feel good if
I feel gross doing that but I may work
with a company like Microsoft or Dell or
American Express and create content for
their website that is helping
entrepreneurs it's not just promotional
I have my own guides zuga guides and
these guides help entrepreneurs go
through all the struggles like getting
me in a room for two hours to help you
through whatever problem you're facing
and then I do speaking and the speaking
is you know around the world I get paid
to go deliver various speeches on
different topics and help entrepreneurs
and it all come out of
passion and love helping entrepreneurs
if I were you how it would get started
if I was trying to build up a coaching
practice what I would do is first of all
figure out who your market is right like
who are you trying to help so a coach
tons of coaches who specifically do you
want to help and be known as a person
who does this and then start providing
really great amazing information and I
would do a two pronged approach one
where I have my own channel so create
your own channel yeah I love YouTube I
get a lot of business deals from YouTube
but if you could start on Twitter or a
blog if you're not comfortable in front
of the camera and share your best stuff
you know people but they watch your
video if they read your tweet if they
read your blog they should feel like wow
Antoinette really knows what she's
talking about that that was great that
made me think about what I'm doing and
at the same time so this is helping you
build your own audience at the same time
start reaching out to people who have an
audience that is exactly like yours and
offer to do an interview with them a
guest post from them a guest video
whatever it is get involved in their
community have them introduce you to
their community and what its going to
lead to them you know you do some kind
of interview right you do it I do this
all the time do interviews with other
people who reach out to entrepreneurs
the entrepreneurs of the interview they
listen in I get introduced to this whole
new audience that I didn't reach before
and they say well they learn more go
check out Evan Carmichael calm so
they'll come and check out my website
right after the interview they're gonna
go check out your website you have to
have stuff on there that engages people
video blog post tweets whatever it is so
you have to run those paths in parallel
you start creating your own community
with your best stuff stuff that moves
people stuff that matter stuff that when
you read you get excited about and
combine that with reaching out to people
who already serve your target audience
and showcase yourself as an expert you
just add any value you're not selling
anything you just add in value and the
opportunities will come right if people
see all this great stuff you're creating
you may not just be a coach anymore
right you may get speaking gigs you may
get media gigs you may get a book deal
you may get a clothing line you know who
knows all this stuff can come
but you have to pour your heart into
creating amazing content for your
audience to make them feel something and
say I need more Antoinette
you make that happen and you're on your
way to create a successful practice
believe who's your watching like the
video give her a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment ask
me a question below I'll make a video
response like this one and subscribe to
the channel by clicking on my face thank
you guys so much I'll see you soon